yeah you know something i'll start off
with a political question i i don't care
about the politics i care about making
sure we have a vibrant
area to do business in that's the number
one priority and whatever it takes to
get the give the police the tools to go
in there and and get these people moving
on you know guys i get it you know
everyone's frustrated i'm just as
frustrated as anyone else we want to get
through this i want to get these
mandates moving and we made some great
announcements yesterday on in two days
we're going to be going to 100 in
restaurants on march the 1st we're just
going to open things up and thank god uh
you know and i'm no secret that you know
with these uh passports vax passports i
i wasn't sold on them but went along and
we did what we had to do because
the the doctor said we need to do this
so now moving forward the doc says hang
in there for the for the mast i respect
him you know dr moore is phenomenal but
you know something he's reasonable too
he's reasonable he gets it he
understands the economy
and
i think he's done an incredible job
but thank god on march the 1st
we're moving forward out of this and
then man i just can't wait
really can't wait my question was about
the emergencies act though like what um
what specifically do you want to see
happen to end the occupation in ottawa
and um
yeah like politically the question was
more why do you support this
actually i understand so it's given the
police the tools that they need to move
the occupiers on it's easy for us to sit
here in toronto and in hamilton and
around the gta imagine
being held hostage a million people
they they can't go downtown they can't
even go to the mall downtown to go
shopping
it's crazy and again i'm the first to
say
the we have the right to protest and we
have
i believe in freedoms and liberties in
this country
and i'd never ever want to squash that
but when you're holding up the economy
and you're costing 700 million dollars
and that's just short term long term
some companies just say that's it
we're out of here we're gone you never
get them back
that's our goal
and so they're we're moving along we
have the bridge open now and they they
did some great work now let's just clean
up ottawa folks let's unite this country
i've never seen this country in this
province
so divided you know it is affected
friendships affected co-workers it's
affected families
and i can tell you guys
i faced all three of them and man it's
it's challenging
especially on the
on the family side
hi good morning premier
i wanted to ask you about
the situation in ottawa so you brought
in the emergency orders on friday the
ambassador bridge seemed to have been
resolved pretty quickly after that so
can you give us in your view what is a
reasonable time frame to wrap up the
situation in ottawa people have been
dealing with it for three weeks now what
what in your view should be a reasonable
time frame now that three levels of
government have declared states of
emergency well all the three levels of
police forces are working together
calling that's the municipal and
provincial and federal and i i can't i
you know obviously everyone knows i
don't direct the police i'm not allowed
to direct them and i have no need to we
have just phenomenal police officers and
hopefully they're going to move them on
as quickly as possible but i just asked
the protesters guys we're moving out of
this
why why why cause pain the ironic thing
is calling
they're saying the freedoms we're giving
freedoms but they're hurting more people
than the pandemic could ever hurt ever
hundreds of thousands of jobs millions
of families you know as simple as even
the food processing companies can't get
certain ingredients
certain widgets can't get across the
border like you just you can't hold up
the economy in effect hundreds of
thousands of families so
to answer your question more directly
hopefully the the police in the in the
next little while few days hopefully
sooner
can move on but you know folks it's
complicated ottawa you know what makes
it complicated they have the kids there
and kids are our priority right we don't
want anything to happen to any kids so
please just move
bring your kids home and
guys let's just unite that's all i'm
asking forget all this nonsense we're in
such a competitive environment
and we're all fighting amongst ourselves
well not all of us but a small
percentage is is
fighting against the rest
let's just get along that's all i want